[Music]
numerous times in the last five years
Venezuelan dictator Nicolas Maduro has
crushed pro-democracy demonstrations
however Venezuelans who are taking to
the streets now to reclaim their freedom
from an operative tater ship they
finally have a fighting chance the
United States and much of the
international community are backing Juan
Y dole as the legitimate president of
Venezuela democracies in the region have
a great deal at stake in ensuring a
turnaround in Venezuela they should warn
Maduro of dire consequences if he uses
violence against Y though or other
innocent civilians they should also
recognize why those authority on all
economic and diplomatic decisions in the
region in the United States should
deliver humanitarian assistance the
moment president y doll and the National
Assembly authorized such operations on
Venezuelan territory if there is a
murderous crackdown against
demonstrators these governments must be
prepared to protect human life
from the regime Venezuela's friends must
continue to act boldly to defend
economic and political freedom in that
country how do you think we should react
to events in Venezuela let us know in
your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI